another day I'm going into another
evening funny how the manpower shortage
hits us every day about this time
manpower I'd settle for one without
earning power you know we're getting
into a rut
oh girl grace let's celebrate celebrate
what must be somebody's birthday just
think a nice juicy steak and then the
Becky on town and afterwards we could go
somewhere and listen to some music just
like old times
almost it's a great idea well shoot the
works
I can see spots in front of my eyes
shaped like tea box so pizza butcher to
see if they're real thank you 27 points
please but you see we had to rush right
over you to get here before 6:00 and we
didn't have time to go home for our
ration books besides we don't have
enough quiet up this week for that stage
would you the difference next to me
please
here's the money in dollar 35 I'm gonna
pay more I'll give you two dollars for
the steak how about that two and a half
and we'll still have enough left for the
rest of the evening
Lady Luck the ceiling prices 45 cents a
pound and that's all I can charge
but I've got the hair of 27 points can't
you forget the red tape just this once
we don't need red tape we need red meat
lady that's a butcher I didn't want to
insult a customer but as a citizen I'm
getting a little fed up let's face it
son crustose lady don't break a price
ceiling you love bigger hit by a falling
pasta what a delicious dinner
it's all right with me that's silly
butcher doesn't want to take our money
what a dope it's all that eration
board's fault last week I couldn't even
get an extra pair of shoes week before
it was gasoline it's trying to run our
lives for us you know that second
butcher must be making a fortune shows
what it happen without price ceilings
yeah but six dollars for a steak keep
feeling my teeth in case I bit into a
diamond oh well what if we couldn't go
to a show or any place afterwards just
gave us more time to enjoy our steak
there's nothing like going to bed with a
good book
if the boy had its way to be a racing
horse
what are you doing here
get out of here you called for me don't
call for anybody you call for me
I'm your conscience you're my butcher if
you don't get out of here I'll scream
yeah
they will do any good no one could hear
a dream scream and besides you can't get
away from your consciousness okay
conscience what next I want both you
girls to come and meet the Racing Board
get the facts fine I was all about
before you complain Oh break the rules
that's great with me I've been waiting
for a chance to tell them off but will
they be working this late oh sure they
stay awake all night thinking up new
rules come on come on good you're off
he's slow
good evening evening
that's the chairman of the local board
this is Louise and Gracie they want to
make a complaint a complaint you
certainly come to the right place come
in what that tell you he's got horns
yeah that's how people see when they
don't worry about learning the facts
would you mind explaining the reason of
racing to these girls
you feed large amounts of foods like
meat butter canned fruits and vegetables
are going to war now in order to see
that everyone gets a chance to buy his
or her fair share we raishin share and
share alike and then to keep down the
cost to a reasonable level and eliminate
profiteering we're put ceiling prices on
these foods without these ceiling prices
the scarce goods would simply go to
those with the most money a fair share
at a fair price that's the purpose of
rationing and price ceiling oh I don't
care anything about that I came here to
protest all right Gracie just before you
start panning a table like you to know
that he is a volunteer worker outside of
a few paint clerks all the local boards
are comprised of periodic citizens
walking work far into the night you you
mean to say he isn't in the business he
doesn't get paid no of course not a
lawyer I'm pretty busy these days on my
own - you mean you work that hard for
free certainly you can take those off
now thank you
there are about 5,200 boards like this
all around the United States every
community has its individual problems
representative men make up the local
boards it gives us a feeling we're
contributing to the war effort ensuring
the flow of guns to the soldiers into
the home front but they aren't being
delivered to us why not call the whole
thing off and to save us a lot of
trouble and you a lot of time that'll be
all right to me
worrying about points and changing
ceiling prices driving me Daffy sure
it's a lot of bother and a lot of extra
work nobody likes it nobody wants it but
it's the lesser of two evils if you
really want to call this whole thing off
well we're only doing it to protect you
so it's alright with me let's go to the
store and stock up before everything is
gone
look at the prices
be back honey just send me over
everything you got
yeah holgie for view ballpark
ten dollars a pound that deep wholesale
boy that's double what I'm selling it
for oh boy are you cleaning up we're
losing everything the prices we paid the
growers the railroads and the workers
are shooting up faster than we can
change our prices and they need money so
they can buy from you retailers
everything's gone crazy everybody loses
I
you're sure none of you wanted rationing
I wanted rationing and price ceiling I
live on the allotment my boy sends me
he's in the South Pacific I guess
everybody like me who lives on a fixed
income is out of luck if crackers a
dollar a box
I'm afraid my allotment won't buy enough
to eat
Louise I'm ashamed so my
maybe maybe if we go to the racing board
next and apologize listen let's go over
the board and make him difference our
racing parts and price savings again a
lot of trouble
did you wake me up with that I was
dreaming about Charles Boyer I have a
wonderful dream right - who that
marvellous handsome Racing Board
Chairman grace from now on I'm gonna pay
all my points for everything I get an
observe the price ceilings boy I sure
learned my lesson